you love these movies these Marvel  movies I don't love them no I don't I  know I don't hate them all right but I  don't love them I mean look I used to  collect Marvel Comics like crazy when I  was a kid and so there's an aspect that  if these movies were coming out when I  was in my 20s I would totally be [ __ ]  happy and totally love them I mean they  wouldn't be the only movies being made  there would be those movies amongst  other movies my only axed grind against  them is they're the only things that  seem to be made yeah and they're the  only things that seem to generate any  kind of excitement right amongst the fan  base or just or even like uh for the  studio making them all right that's  that's what they're excited about true  and uh you know so it's just the fact  that you know the entire representation  of this era of movies right now right  and there's not really much room for for  anything else that is literally my  problem it's a problem of representation